[Music]
the future is looking a lot brighter
here in las vegas all around the country
as well as covid numbers continue to
decline
but the process can be slow over the
past year we've told you about families
who need some help at
thanksgiving and christmas and for many
the picture is much the same as we
approach easter
sasha loft is joining us live tonight
with more on one couple's plan to
make the easter holiday a bit brighter
brian we first introduced you to jim and
julie danner back in november
as they delivered hundreds of
thanksgiving meals to families in need
across las vegas
now they're looking to do the same this
easter and they're calling on the
community for help
they're still in need people are still
in a lot of need you might remember
julie and jim danner so crazy too
they've spent the last year dedicating
their lives to helping others
make ends meet there's hundreds and
thousands of people
in this town in this community you know
helping each other
doing what they can we first met the
danners back in november
when they delivered thanksgiving meals
to hundreds of las vegas families
now they're turning their attention to
easter gathering
400 meals and 1200 holiday baskets
for kids and families in need even if
they could manage it but it would leave
them ten dollars in their account
we would rather give them that stuff so
maybe they have a hundred dollars in
their account
but they need everyone's input to make
it happen
with any extra food or change you can
spare i don't care if you donate a
dollar
as long as you know you get you get it
to us
and and we can use it for taking care of
families around town
so if you're looking for a way to help
consider
starting here with two people who are
living proof of what it means
to make a difference we never judge and
we just try to help where we can
and we just hope what we're doing is
enough
jim and julie do need a lot of food and
supplies still to make all these easter
wishes come true in just a week and a
half
if you'd like to donate food or funds or
even volunteer to make deliveries
we have more information on our website
8newsnow.com
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now